so thank you on behalf of Book Lovers
and book clubs everywhere for sharing
your talents with us and for everything
you do to promote literacy and a love of
literature
please keep doing so
and please remain true to your calling
unimpeded by those who may wish to curb
the freedom of your expression or impose
limits on your imagination
foreign
it's a huge pleasure to welcome you all
writers Publishers and book clubbers to
Clarence House
a week late but covered free so thank
you thank you very much for re-checking
your busy Diaries and coming today say a
few words as one of the trustees of this
new charity but before I do can I just
say how wonderful it is for all of us to
be in our Majesty's home and to have as
our king and queen people that we know
love literature love books to have such
Champions as our king and queen is
simply fantastic it really is so we are
thrilled to read it
okay
yes
hello
[Music]
um
I've never had